dieses auto ist für mercedes so wichtig
wie der golf für vws ist die mercedes
s-klasse ein wahres statussymbol und das
schon seit jahren ein wenig stunden wird
die neue s klasse vorgestellt und
darüber wollen wir jetzt schon einmal
sprechen denn bei mir im studio jetzt
vom drexler unser auto chefredakteur bei
bild was ist das besondere an der s
klasse was macht sich schon seit so
vielen jahren zu einem der beliebtesten
autos
die s klasse ist ein weltauto das sind
autovaz kurioserweise in allen schichten
eigentlich als statussymbol gilt zum
beispiel beim handwerksmeister der es
geschafft hat aber auch bei einem
oligarchen bei einem despoten bei
rappern bei sängerin alicia keys fährt
ein
also hat der s klasse das ist dann so
ein globales phänomen alle fühlen darin
ihren status bestätigt
und was ist das besondere jetzt an der
neuen s-klasse die heute also
vorgestellt wird das neue liegt in ich
durfte schon mitfahren in der s klasse
und der fahrer das sehen wir jetzt auch
im display dort der kopf durchs lenkrad
auf ein display und das display ist ein
3d display das heißt dass gaukelte eine
tiefe von einem halben meter vor
ungefähr du guckst da rein ohne 3d
brille und das trotzdem ein 3d effekt
und wenn deine augen bisschen höher
waren dann hast du ein augmented reality
display und das funktioniert bei anderen
noch nicht bei mercedes funktioniert ist
das zeichnet die so ähnlich wie ein
videospiel zehn meter vor der auf der
straße linien also das rote linien grüne
linien abbiege pfeile und das führt dazu
dass du dich wesentlich sicherer fürst
das erkennt andere autos das ordnet die
einem verkehr und diese s klasse kann
zum beispiel theoretisch nächstes jahr
wird das wahrscheinlich auch in
deutschland legal als erstes land der
welt in der autonom stufe 3 fahren das
heißt du kannst die hände vom lenkrad
nehmen und kann es bis 60 km h auf einer
autobahn autonom fahren jetzt wirst du
sagen auf der autobahn 60 schneller aber
das auto verkauft sich ja auch viel in
ländern wie china wie andere ländern wo
man tatsächlich morgens zwei stunden hin
und zwei stunden zurück braucht und man
fährt dort gar nicht schneller als 60
weil die autobahn alle voll sind und
dieses auto ermöglicht dir dass du dann
völlig automatisch fahren kannst
du kannst dabei lesen du musst die
zeitung hat so tief halten dass die
kamera hat sich immer noch sehen kann
und auch noch eine besonderheit das auto
kann dich fingerabdruck erkennen wie
dein handy zum beispiel was ein handy
schon kann oder durch eine
gesichtserkennung und dann funktioniert
alles ganz gut wie hier muss ich jetzt
hinlegen für all diese neuen chefs also
echte preis und daher bekannt gegeben es
wird unter 100.000 losgehen aber ehrlich
gesagt unter 100000 wird davon kein auto
über die ladentheke gehen weil mit ein
paar kleinen extras ist es dann doch
wieder sehr viel teurer als die dann
unbegrenzt hoch fast unbegrenzt hoch
klingt teuer du hast ja schon gesagt ist
ein statussymbol für alle möglichen
menschen für handwerker für rapper für
politiker jetzt wenn wir nur auf
deutschland schauen wer kann sich hier
also dann so ein auto leisten wo sehen
wie die neue s-klasse da hat mal geguckt
also wie bei also ich bin noch vor ich
bin voll drin weil so ab 55 sind die
typischen deutschen s-klasse käufer die
sind so um die 55 jahre alt in china zum
beispiel sind sie 40 bei denen es
manchmal das erste auto überhaupt was
sie besitzen viele fahren das auch
selber und das ist ja auch zu schade bei
dieser ist klasse sie nicht selbst zu
fahren weil die hat seine
hinterradlenkung damit kannst du sehr
sportlich fahren die linken mit die
hinterräder und du kannst mit einem fünf
meter 27 jahre langen auto sehr
sportlich fahren als wäre das auto einen
meter kürzer ja ich glaube dass es gibt
in deutschland ja noch einige vermögende
menschen und reiche menschen und ganz
ehrlich gesagt wer bezahlt heute schon
ein auto in bar
das stimmt wahrscheinlich also um 14 uhr
wird das auto dann heute vorgestellt und
natürlich alles was wir dann erfahren
bei bild dann zu sehen vielen dank viel
gibt es jetzt schon zu lesen
auch jetzt natürlich schon wir abdecken
das seinen vielen dank auf jeden fall
für diese einblicke jetzt schon mal
dagegen